welcome back everybody it is National
sock day which was created by the next
three guests that are here they are the
founders of pair of Thieves a clothing
company that happens to make super comfy
socks if you know me at all I'm all my
friends with that I'm obsessed with
socks like you know people get that for
Christmas I love getting socks for
Christmas anyway um and but you know
people family members like why did you
give me socks give me socks anyway and
what started out as a fun idea has
turned into a deeply meaningful Mission
which is even better please welcome Alan
Stewart Dave aronburg and Cash Warren
everybody so welcome to the show thank
you so much you guys have been friends
for a minute right we have we we we grew
up together you know when I when I had
the idea to start pair of Thieves I I I
knew I'm not a Mr know at all I don't
have all the answers and so I I knew I
needed Partners to to take the idea and
make it a bit stronger and so I reached
out to two childhood friends uh to to
help me launch we've been at this for 31
years of friendship oh my gosh yes
starting a business like a marriage yeah
well sometimes it doesn't work out I
hope the best for
you so I've heard um so how did how did
the sock thing happen where did that
come from why socks so we knew There's
an opportunity to make better socks when
we started this like 10 years ago there
just weren't good socks out there and so
we said can we take style performance
and affordability and mash them all up
and that was what gave birth to para of
Thieves yeah I love the name too such a
cool name so tell us about the cause
behind this yeah I mean when we were out
one day as a company giving socks out
and and to people in need living on the
streets we got this guy who came up to
me and said you know these are like gold
when you're homeless and so at that
moment we knew that something small
could turn into something big and since
then we've partnered up with a great
organization called baby to baby and
we've donated over 3 million pairs of
socks today yeah you don't think about
that but that would be something that's
like shoes or socks like think you don't
I never really thought about that but
super important super important and they
have to be donated new you don't donate
you socks and so uh it takes companies
like ours to step up and and really try
to make a difference um and so we
started National sock day as kind of a
fun light-hearted way to raise attention
and raise awareness how do you get a
national day for something so cool so we
were really jealous of tacos getting
Tuesday so we were like love Taco
Tuesday so we were like how do we get to
one for socks and there is a national
day calendar organization that governs
all these kind of random day holidays
that you see popping up everywhere and
we applied we wrote an essay and of the
18, you wrot an essay I've never seen
you work harder I don't I will get this
I will get it and we rewarded the day
and so December 4th is National Stock
day uh today it is very much a day of
service for the company uh we we we
volunteered organizations this year
we're volunteering at baby to baby in
the past we've donated at shelter
Partnerships and a number of others um
but it it feels good to get out and and
to really recognize something so small
can make the biggest difference in
someone's life 100% and how cool is it
that you get to do with like friends
that you've grown up with and you get to
do something like that you love to do
together but also is an impact like in
the world that's cool um well what's the
bigger mission of the company what's the
the big thing so you know we started out
as a sock brand um but as as our
products have expanded to underwear and
the shirts and and you know the the the
customer base is expanded our give back
has as well and so today we have a
wonderful partnership with an
organization um called the Trevor
Project for
lgbtq um
and thank you we donate hundreds of
thousands of dollars in product to that
organization every year uh we're all
dads and so Teen Mental Health is
incredibly important to us and so we
support an organization called bring
change to mind uh and then as Allan
mentioned babyto baby is our partnership
for families in need yeah it's so funny
we all have children here I think when
we were all kids mental health was still
a very important thing but I think
social media has just really just blown
up everything and that's just it's more
important now than ever for kids to
really have great self-esteem all right
so how can everybody get involved what
should they do you know in honor of us
being here today we wanted to announce
that you know every on for December 4th
and December 5th everything on para of
thieves. comom will donate 100% of our
net proceeds to charity and so wow thank
you so if you're looking for a great
gift know that you're per you're
purchasing with a purpose and and we are
going to support organizations
purchasing with a purpose that should be
a shirt it should be a sweatshirt y'all
make I would buy that too that's so nice
but that's really cool everybody for
more information on how you can make a
difference this National sock day
because they worked hard for that head
to our there was an essay people head to
our
[Music]
socials
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home